Picture this.
You have the opportunity
to own a beautiful home
in a historic neighborhood
with deep cultural roots
designed by some of the best
urban planners in the world.
all in a charming waterfront city.
You'd want to live here, right?
But what if I told you
that this home was in an area of Baltimore
called the Black Butterfly,
where block after block
of these beautiful historic row homes
sit vacant and are negatively valued,
meaning that the cost to repair each home
is actually more than
what the market says it's worth.
Somehow the market must be broken. Right?
What's going on here?
I’ve been studying the way
housing markets work -- or don’t work --
for the last decade.
I started my career
in investment finance on Wall Street,
but when my hometown
on the outskirts of New York City
began to be gentrified,
it pushed me into becoming
a housing advocate.
I learned more about the racist policies
mandated by federal and local governments
like redlining and urban renewal
that gutted once thriving
Black communities across the country
and prevented Black citizens
from building wealth
through homeownership.
These communities
typically face two trajectories.
The first is a downward spiral,
where political
and financial disinvestment
causes hypervacancy and decay
that pushes people out of a neighborhood.
Big banks see this exodus as confirmation
that these neighborhoods are risky,
defeated, unredeemable.
And so without investment,
the cycle of distress continues.
The second trajectory is gentrification,
where developers are able
to capitalize off of this distress
by buying undervalued properties,
pumping money into them
without considering
the needs or wants of legacy residents,
and then renting or reselling them
at much, much higher costs,
causing displacement.
So my question became:
Can we do development
without displacement?
Is there another way?
I quit my job on Wall Street
and moved to Baltimore,
the city that birthed redlining,
with a single suitcase to find out.
My first inclination was
to meet with investors
and, you know, to raise funds for my idea.
And I was literally
laughed out of the room.
They said that my idea was impossible
and that we would build homes
that would sit empty for lack of demand.
But I knew in my heart of hearts
that that wasn't true.
Unexpectedly in that moment,
being rejected by investors was
the most important moment in my journey,
because I realized
that we didn't need big institutions
to affirm the value of our communities.
We’d affirm our own value
through social capital.
And so I started my non-profit, Parity,
which creates upfront demand
for homeownership opportunities
in neighborhoods experiencing hypervacancy
simply by tapping
into existing social networks.
What started as an idea from just one
has grown into a collective movement
of eight, then 19
and now 44 future homeowners.
All through word of mouth.
And we have a waitlist of over --
(Applause)
Thank you.
And we now have a waitlist
of over 100 people
wanting to join our intentional community.
Like Yolanda,
who's ready to buy a home
to leave a legacy for her daughters.
Or Jenee,
a fourth-generation Baltimorean
whose father vividly remembers
the demolition of black homes
to make way for a highway to nowhere.
Ako, whose family left
West Baltimore when he was just a baby
but now is coming back home to his origins
to be part of the revitalization.
And Modinat, who like me,
came to Baltimore from New York
to settle down and build a future.
There are three key reasons
why our work is transformational.
The first is that we are
leading the purchase and renovation
of dozens of decades-long
abandoned buildings
and reselling them
at deeply affordable price points.
The second is that we not only
support our homebuyers
to become credit-qualified
and mortgage-approved,
but we're creating the opportunity
for folks to build deep social bonds
and friendships
with their future neighbors.
And three, we're preventing
the displacement of legacy residents
by ensuring that they have the resources
that they need to stay in their homes
and transfer their wealth
to the next generation.
We're healing the social fabric
of the neighborhood
as we're rebuilding the built environment.
Contrary to the dominant narrative,
there absolutely is demand for housing
in historically Black neighborhoods
devastated by racist policy.
We've tapped into a hunger and appetite
hiding in the blind spots
of the traditional capital markets.
Remember those folks
that laughed me out of the room?
Well, we have more --
Within just two years' time,
we now have more demand for our homes
than we have homes.
We're sold out.
And so can we do development
without displacement?
We absolutely can.
Thank you.
(Applause)